coup de frein pour le développement de
l'éolien terrestre
emmanuel macron souhaite freiner l'essor
de la filière sous la pression
manifestement des élus locaux alors que
le pays a confié repassait la partie de
l'éolien dans la production
d'électricité de 7% aujourd'hui à 20% en
2028 l'exécutif dénonçons développement
anarchique sur le territoire
le secteur de l'énergie éolienne se dit
préoccupé la face à la montée des
critiques
il appelle au dialogue et rappelle le
choix du pays de développer cette
énergie et pour en parler nous sommes en
direct avec jean louis bal président du
syndicat des énergies renouvelables
monsieur balle bien le bonjour merci
d'être avec nous alors est ce qu'on peut
parler d'un rétro pédalage à quelques
temps on nous vole et on nous vendait
cette énergie renouvelable éolien et
puis maintenant on veut freiner son
essor
alors ce président et ralentissements
c'est un peu une interprétation je
dirais politique d'un journaliste si je
reviens aux vrais propos tenus par le
président de la république c'est qu'il a
fait le constat que l'énergie éolienne
ne faisait pas ne faisait plus l'objet
de consensus ans dans la population
or c'est un constat que je ne partage
pas donc ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on
a des anti-éoliens et les pro éoliens on
a toujours eu des antilles et et odien
ce qui est nouveau c'est qu'on a un
certain nombre d'hommes politiques de
poids comme le président de la région de
france où dominique bussereau de en
charente maritime qui ont pris le relais
des associations anti-éoliennes et c'est
ça qui remonte aux oreilles du président
mais ce n'est pas un véritable
indicateur de l'acceptation de l'énergie
éolienne par la population nous sur le
terrain ce qu'on constate c'est que
cette énergie est toujours bien acceptée
c'est la deuxième énergies renouvelables
plébiscité par les français après le
solaire donc il n'ya pas de vrai
problème de d'acceptabilité et
d'ailleurs à la suite de la parution cet
article
la ministre de la transition énergétique
et écologique parents et solidaire
madame bornman m'a appelé pour me
rassurer
et dire que le gouvernement avait
toujours la volonté de réaliser donc les
objectifs qui sont dans la loi qui sont
dans la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie qui va bientôt être publié et
nous partageons un constat c'est qu'il y
a aujourd'hui une trop grande
concentration d'éoliennes dans deux
régions en particulier qui sont allés
aux trans ou et des grands tests et donc
il y a actuellement un groupe de travail
qui étaient mis en place par la ministre
qui travaillent sur des mécanismes pour
organiser une meilleure répartition de
l'éolien sur vous êtes d'accord
actuellement éolien est mal répartie sur
le territoire français il est trop
concentré donc les deux régions que
j'hésitais deux le sont à peu près 50 7
% du parc éolien total et donc il
faudrait aller sur d'autres zones
ce qui signifie aussi qu'il faut
peut-être réduire les contraintes
réglementaires qu'on a sur le reste du
pays on a à peu près la moitié du pays
qui est contraint par des des
interdictions duo zone d'entraînement de
l'armée due à des radars etc et donc il
faut peut-être ouvrir une partie de ces
zones
donc si je comprends bien on parle du
freinage ne les sort de sept éoliennes
mais vous avez eu elisabeth bornes la
ministre au téléphone il n'est pas du
tout question de freiner cet essor
justement on va implanter des éoliennes
ailleurs en france parce que dans
certaines zones ce serait trop concentré
donc c'est sûr ne me regarde analyse
c'est que il faut au contraire accélérer
le développement de l'énergie éolienne
mais le faire de façon plus harmonieuse
et donc il y aura un certain nombre de
dispositions pour mieux répartir mais
aussi pour rendre plus acceptable par
exemple
les éoliennes sont deux nuits balisé
avec des débats 10 clignotantes ce qui
peut être une gêne pour les riverains
donc avec l'armée on est en train de
travailler à des dispositifs d'abord
pour orienter les balises vers le ciel
l'homme se trouve les aéronefs arrêter
de les faire clignoter ou avoir des
dispositifs qui déclenché ses balises au
moment où un aéronef approche des
éoliennes
voilà ça c'est des choses qui
permettrait de d'améliorer le confort
des riverains
on travaille aussi sur pour répondre aux
critiques que nous font les anti éoliens
sur la question du démantèlement en fin
de vie qui se fait déjà très bien
aujourd'hui mais on nous reproche de
laisser les socles en béton dans le sol
donc la profession d'elle-même a décidé
donc d'excaver complètement les
fondations en béton en fin de vie de
d'organiser au mieux le recyclage des
des aliens lorsqu on les démonte 1 c'est
déjà aujourd'hui recyclé à 95 %
on doit encore faire mieux avec
notamment les pales qui sont aujourd'hui
en matériaux composites et dont on ne
fait en recyclage que de du combustible
pour mettre dans l'est les cimenteries
une des critiques aussi des anti-éoliens
ce serait que ce ne serait pas très joli
que sa veuve ce ne se rendrait pas avec
le paysage actuel
bah écoutez ça c'est un critère qui est
extrêmement subjectif il ya des gens qui
trouve très beau imparable
mais je pense surtout que l'homme a de
tout temps fait évoluer le paysage
il n'ya plus en france de paysage
complètement naturel et donc en
implantant un parc éolien on va faire
effectivement évolué paysage et il faut
le faire en concertation avec les
populations en concertation avec les
collectivités
alors on a un caractère inépuisable dans
le temps de ces énergies renouvelables
contrairement aux énergies dites
fossiles ces énergies renouvelables il y
en a plein l'éolien le solaire et
géothermique
quelle est celle qui s'adapterait le
mieux au territoire français
alors on aura besoin de toutes les
sources d'énergie renouvelables donc
pour atteindre ce qu'on appelle
maintenant la neutralité carbone qui est
un objectif pour 2050 et les types
d'énergies renouvelables qu'on va
utiliser et les très dépendante du type
d'énergie qu'on doit produire si on veut
faire de la chaleur pour chauffer nos
maisons pour chauffer nos industries les
process la géothermie et les usages de
la biomasse le bois énergie
c'est probablement la meilleure la
meilleure source d'énergie si on veut
faire de l'électricité
ben on a le solaire photovoltaïque on à
l'éolien intéresse mais aussi d'éolien
en mer qui dont le développement va
commencer ou vers 2022 il ya un certain
nombre de parts qui sont déjà en
construction
et puis il faut pas oublier que on a
pour l'électricité on a un socle qui
s'appelle l'hydroélectricité qui est
bien une énergie renouvelable et qui
permet d'absorber les variations de
l'éolien du solaire et de la
consommation alors très rapidement on
dit que la france est l'un des plus
mauvais élèves de l'europe en termes de
d'énergies renouvelables parce que c'est
un avis que vous partagez c'est à dire
que nous ne sommes pas dans le port
normand en tout cas dans les meilleurs
de la classe en europe mais on n'est pas
non plus les plus mauvais et on avait
des objectifs pour 2020 dont qui étaient
décidées au niveau européen on
n'atteindra pas on a maintenant des
objectifs pour 2030 et je pense qu'avec
les mesures qui ont été décidées
on devrait atteindre les objectifs de
2030 qui sont de 33 % d'énergie
renouvelable pour l'ensemble de notre
mix énergétique
jean lui bâle merci je rappelle que vous
êtes président du syndicat des énergies
renouvelables
merci merci à vous